the core concept of samasource is
essentially that technology helps us
unlock human talent wherever it may
happen to reside that we should no
longer be victims of the birth lottery
that no one should be stuck in a poor
place where they don't have a job simply
because of an accident of birth and what
technology enables us to do now is to
tap into this brain power through the
internet through a concept that we built
called micro work so Summa sources
mission is to give work to people who
need it most using the Internet and we
do that by sourcing large technology
contracts from big enterprises like
Google LinkedIn eBay walmart.com and
Microsoft which are all our customers
and we gather this work and then we
unitize it into small tasks and the
small tasks we call microwork and then
those small tasks we train people on the
other side of the world to do them from
local computer centers so the tasks
might be as simple as tagging an image
for example we work with the largest
image archive in the world that supplies
images of celebrities for major tabloid
magazines and media agencies we work
with companies that catalogue images as
part of major databases we work with
companies that use images for essential
processes for example one of the
companies we work with uses our image
tagging to teach cars to stop before
they hit a pedestrian to automate the
process of recognizing when a car is
going to be close to a pedestrian that's
a new application of what's called
machine learning so a basic task like
tagging an image and telling us whether
there's a person in this image or
whether this is Rihanna or Andy Samberg
all of these types of tasks can be used
for major applications at the higher end
of the spectrum we do things like
content production so we actually train
people in low-income countries who who
speak English fluently to write content
write custom content for websites
and that's part of a growing need for
people to have unique content on their
website to draw customers to it and this
kind of work didn't exist ten years ago
right I mean we didn't have these
complicated machine learning algorithms
that were teaching cars to you know to
drive by themselves and now that we do
there's a huge need for people to help
with these small tasks with micro work
so the way it works in practice is I
have a team based in San Francisco that
sources work from major companies so we
source these contracts we compete based
on quality and cost and turnaround time
just like any other data services
provider and then on the backend we have
workers all over the world we have about
900 workers globally now in East Africa
South Asia and Haiti who do these micro
these pieces of micro work from these
local computer centers and we partner
with local entrepreneurs who run
computer centers that maintain the
infrastructure for us for the customer
for Google or Microsoft it's just like
working with any other data services
company they can log into our platform
and see the work being done in real-time
but on the back end that looks totally
different it looks like a man waking up
in a rural village in northern Uganda
and walking to a computer center where
there's high-speed Internet and air
conditioning and a computer screen and
where he's able to do these tasks
through our technology platform
you